I also I have  two bro a lot of the reason I do what I  do is I advocate for men's rights so I  have two brothers that like committed  they tried to commit suicide so I just  think the world is harder for men than  the media really lets it be and I I  think feminism  yeah I think it's it's tough on bad I  don't think they advocate for men the  way they should  so I'm sorry to hear that yeah but also  it's if we uplift women men will also be  uplifted to  okay if you uplift women for what for  being women why should we just be  uplifted for being alive  like that's the stupidest [ __ ] I've ever  heard in my life like okay let's let's  uplift men for just being men like no  no  freaking